[Music]
in unaccompanied women news okay
submitted by gimme more JK you shall
receive exclamation point if you want
you get you can also watch our vlog that
you are more JK yeah social media and
there's JK party mhm I will be posting
one day and I um I hang out with him
sometimes so you can watch my stuff too
boy I'll be there he's always trying to
leech off my followers it should yeah
true
III comment on all of arts pictures and
I'm like hey if you like JK related
stuff come to my stuff guys design work
for you do you do it the other way
around here some people are we know I
remember there was a huh there was a
time when you used to leave comments who
me
on pictures on youtubes oh I mean that's
when we all used to watch you till this
video I know that's what we used to do
skids that's gonna be like cared about
each other
Tenley's comments on pictures you know
what I actually started watching JK news
again because we just say [ __ ] that
remember dude you know the the cancer I
emoji one and I wash that again and I'm
[ __ ] tired I was die I just saw that
one like a couple of weeks ago dude that
[ __ ] was so [ __ ] funny I will always
watch ok like I watched the ones that
I'm in like all the time like sometimes
I just as background noise when I'm
taking a shower or [ __ ] cleaning I'll
put on the JK news is that that I'm in
no right no but in sometimes like the
ones with y'all like Jess y'all will
play two with the [ __ ] one we did it
was like we can scramble with the fish
that got caught in the guy's throat that
one's so funny dog like I watched that
one all the times it's when I'm chilling
like fish it on again cuz it cracks me
up
there's some ones here that because we
talk so much like we forget what we say
yeah so it's like a brand new podcast at
me and I'm like man these guys are funny
yeah you guys love you guys man yeah
yeah don't forget about me make it dude
oh he's already like halfway do ah you
know don't forget us right now
when you make yeah he's still here yeah
he's here I'm so come back to do JK no
he has made it I'm working on it working
on it I'm working on the bass come on
come on David's been in movies on me we
don't care about David whatever [ __ ]
called me that before I think that one
hurt oh he called you [ __ ] every day I
know that's where the [ __ ] joke is I
can you [ __ ] cut me some slack guys
please stop fighting Mom and Dad I
trained with him today remember that
movie yeah my brain all right what is it
what is it go go go
a female couple is suing a strip club
after they were turned away for not
having men with them oh that's weird
that's very Weiner face ladies finally
you know how it feels when me and a
bunch of my homies try to go to Vegas
club and go where's your ladies I'm like
we don't have any in your face leave
your face for once in a million time
where's the finally you know what it
feels like to be a man if you ain't got
tape that you can't come in yeah yeah
you almost got me but that's what I'll
call you what's raps if you ain't got
you taint then you came yeah yeah and
coming you can't well he's the rather
someone else be everybody shut the [ __ ]
up
that's a you dude no nice oh damn the
runs do that's right oh we forgot about
that [ __ ] group a couple here Heather
and her wife Sonya we're visiting Miami
of remember Cisco and they decided like
hey let's go check out a strip club wait
real quick are your hands in your pocket
we are that's [ __ ] funny okay go
ahead it's just funny actually
so what's the difference between a
rapper and a jumpsuit that is come on
it's a romper style you know that's
really comfortable comfortable you know
it's funny and this is what I can't wait
every time she does go to the bathroom
that whole thing they do sometimes 31 oh
[ __ ] it open yeah I've been staring at
it all day was halfway forgetting but it
was halfway Lee how long it takes just
to bind me record okay anyway just like
Chinese man feels the [ __ ] silk
pajamas got like 60 of them I go down to
[ __ ] about this dig is so damn good
[Laughter]
so this couple here they let me show you
Heather and Sonja pretty yeah Sonja all
Tovar about their battle interfaces this
is a pretty old lesbian couple pretty
old pretty comma old okay yeah are they
wearing opposite colors on purpose I
mean they're not young you know
literally colors opposite of the color
wheel oh it smells and female oh yeah oh
just look like cotton candy together all
right so they both look like they would
look pretty good eating each other out
yes thanks I'm not hating all right
that's the kind of ones that guys
fantasize about not the kind of ones
that really like softball I did so I are
you trying to find a nice way to say
like the strong ones college volleyball
and that was around the same season as
the softball team not all of them like
you have some I don't know what you're
trying to say but the softball has
somebody say I know what it's trying to
say but there's a powerlifter kinds what
the [ __ ] well you're not a lesbian you
don't talk about no no you're saying you
there's lipstick lesbian it's butch
lesbians yeah that's all yeah but I feel
like butch is so mean these days oh but
golf ball kind is nice yeah they love
softball yeah it's either you get Ellen
DeGeneres or you get Rosie O'Donnell
assault wait no they're both of the
softball economy no but I think Ellen
DeGeneres is very pretty though no but
she's still on the softball Ellen
DeGeneres is a handsome lady yeah yeah
girls she's gay and she was dating this
she the bald one right the ball she was
dating one of my friends oh yeah anyway
she was so she was dating this like this
this other like this girl who was like
like like low-key buff and like and like
like just in the handsome in the face
and I know I didn't know how to
compliment her girlfriend I was like
yeah yo she's a trainer right yeah a
6-pack see the power that is in tønsberg
is you
yes and also hey yo yo girl ism handsome
yeah she was like thank you so there's
also those pretty looking dude right mmm
like that guy in peaky blinders the the
main guy was dead he's very pretty
I couldn't get into that shot that's the
that's the Broadway kind of gay yeah
okay I get you
yeah that's the Broadway Broadway kinda
game pretty ins in pretty gays yeah word
that's time that's the you know like
like like the like the police gay that's
like you don't know the band or the long
form no no like the like gay guys that
are in the police force you know like
they're you know the do you know there's
there's that kind and then there's the
makeup artist kind do you guys want to
hear about this trip oh yeah please yeah
I'm just informing people the difference
wait I'm not waiting for this story but
no one army Mart's getting impatient
yeah alright so these women we're
talking about the strip clubs they got
they said no you cannot come in and then
I would've let them in she was like what
what do you mean and then the dude told
her you can't come in unless you are
accompanied by a man and that's when she
was like this is blatant discrimination
I can't get into the club because I'm
not with the man what so she ended up
suing the club oh [ __ ] and and so they
were saying that that it's their company
policy to not allow unless courted
ladies into the dangerous weave without
seeking management approval first
because they could easily be girlfriends
or wives looking for their husbands
caused a ruckus causing like a domestic
situation so they're trying to avoid
that
or it could be prostitutes going in and
interest clients so
the reason why they don't do it and
apparently this is a the club owner said
that it was a common practice throughout
Miami strip clubs to not let
unaccompanied that's true I remember
them telling me that that's interesting
because isn't it pretty common for like
a group of girls to go instead of just
two let's go yeah but cuz we saw that
[ __ ] in Vegas when we [ __ ] Gina was
throwing the money there was a [ __ ]
handful of Asian girls just chillin
right there thrown [ __ ] money and
strippers love when girls come to the
strip club I mean the strippers I know
love with like they would like they
would much rather be stripping for girls
then dude I mean the girls aren't trying
to like I rather be stripper for girls
than dude okay of course yeah this new
site they ended up doing more
investigating and then they found out
that there was these other females that
also sued a different strip club for the
same reason and then when the producers
of this media site when they went his
muse site when they went to these strip
clubs with - it was two women that were
unaccompanied by men they let them in so
then they're saying that maybe because
of these lawsuits now they've changed
the policy or they don't restrict women
from seat and now they let the
prostitutes in they well that they will
revamp the way they filter out
undesirables yeah I mean cuz I mean they
have security there for a reason right I
mean like cuz it's messed up I feel like
if you're a paying customer if you like
girls you should be able to go look at
some zeros look [ __ ] this is my
girlfriend we want carpet mm-hmm let us
in mm-hmm but then if they come in all
steamy and [ __ ] like like they're ready
to fight they're all mad like oh girl
she's not picking up his fall you get a
girl then and you hear them like hype
talking [ __ ] you're like you're not
coming in you're here looking for your
cheatin ass husband and he spends a lot
of money in here so protecting him
[Music]
[Music]